what do you see as the most crucial
chapter for your book
hope for film ah
and why
as opposed to like identifying like a
core chapter in the book i think there's
several takeaways
that i find that come through in each
chapter
the first and kind of most resonant
thing that i
found when i read the book you know
proofing it for myself
was what i say is there's no template
for what is the proper
way to direct what is the proper way to
produce what is a proper way to
collaborate
you have to approach each thing as a
custom
fit how are we going to make it work
a lot of the things that we're taught in
film schools and so on are
we observe on film sets that we think
often is given
if you subscribe to that notion
it's going to restrict your
opportunities the
the most case in point i see on that is
decisiveness
right we're told that we want directors
to always lead to be the person that can
make up their mind
on the spot and say we're doing this and
some of the best directors
who've made the most beautiful movies
i've been
lucky to collaborate on aren't
particularly decisive
they're weighing the decision they're
human beings right
they're having to figure that out and i
think they might have been overlooked
if that's what somebody was looking for
in a director
right each time i think you really need
as a producer
to learn how that director wants to work
right and build your structure to allow
that
sometimes they're not going to be great
on set
at deciding what to do when something
changes that's just who they are
and it doesn't mean they're not going to
give you something truly unique that has
that stamp
of individuality on it the second thing
that really resonates for me in looking
over the book
is how much chaos how much
other stuff happens on movies you know i
i like to speak
i mention it today of producing is to
simply managing complexity
right that that things go wrong you have
to accept it that's why this production
to deal with the the problems but
looking through my movies each one
almost had this moment where
the movie collapsed or somebody went
crazy
or something went terribly wrong
and if i shared that with my director
or if i shared that with my financier or
my distributor
more could have happened but i as the
producer
and or the producing team you know had
to shoulder that
had to find a way to solve it get it
done in a lot of ways in my
my experience that is almost the
signature event of the movie
but sometimes my collaborators didn't
know anything about it
because i had to shield them from yet
another
problem that wasn't going to be about
telling
a great story the final
thing that inc in an overall that has
resonated for me
today with the book is that
it's very easy to think we're
responsible
for everything that happens to us right
that
it's our hard work or our good ideas
or our great taste that has allowed
these things to happen
in thinking it through i started to
recognize
the privilege that i've had you know
starting with being a white
middle-class male in america
that those four things
gave me entree that many people
are denied it gave me access it gave me
opportunity
i also had a lot of good fortune that a
lot of
things that that i was able to to help
build or launch partially came about
because of a scene because of a
collective
effort right because we all
wanted to go to new york at that
particular time
you know some friends have been really
generous and saying wow reading your
book
it's like the launching of american
independent film you were there when it
all happened yes i was there and so it
was about another 150 other people who
were doing
the same thing it's like oh you
discovered ang lee
yeah i discovered angley when he walked
into my office
you discovered you know your assistants
anthony bregman great producer glenn
basner great
film sales person yeah when they walked
into my office i discovered that
but you know and with all the directors
that i've uh
worked with they're wonderful
super talented people but they were
always diamonds
you know they're easy to spot right they
give off a glow
what they needed was somebody to you
know cut the carrots so that they really
you know were allowed to be as glorious
as they
they could be you know i think it's
really important to see
that it's always a team effort
it requires a bit of good fortune of
being in the right place at the right
time
and that there are always a series of
events
be behind what is happening at the time
right you had to get there i often
felt as a young man you know i dropped
out of college
i was incredibly dedicated and
passionate
obsessed with with making independent
movies which i didn't know what they
were yet they were still
you know coming into their own but at
the same time
you know i had a family that would have
taken care of me
if i ran out of money and i had to come
back home
i might have been living you know pretty
spoon to mouth
but there was a place that i could go to
i wasn't on my own i had a support
structure
you know people welcomed me when i
walked into their office
right and i was trained on
societal conventions of how to conduct
myself
i was able to do those things and that
helped a lot i was i was fortunate
so i think those four aspects i guess
are all really kind of key
to how can you
lead a creative life i hope the final
takeaway that people have in the book
is i recognize i was i was fortunate
early in my career that i made a movie
that i loved
that i was told was unsellable it was a
total
failure right people looked at it and
said this film
just won't sell to anybody it's gay
it's chinese and it feels like a film
from the 1940s
except it's gay in chinese right the
film won
the berlin film festival it was angley's
second movie
the wedding banquet and my business
partner james sheamus and i
had to sell it ourselves because it had
been rejected everywhere
and we took a seven hundred thousand
dollar film
sold it for three million dollars across
every territory in the world
at a low sales fee which returned more
money back to our investors
which made them do another film right
away with angly
and i was able to have the the clarity
of that moment
to recognize that the industry
the business was lagging behind
where the art the artists the audience
the technology was
we had all moved faster and the legacy
practices
couldn't work for what we were doing we
were able to start a sales company
based on that experience we found a it
was at that berlin film festival that i
met david lindy
who became the third partner in good
machine right built our sales company
through the work that he did and through
that model that that we committed to we
made 45
films that we financed ourselves without
having any capital
we owned half of those movies right
i think that if you read the book and
you think about today
not just the past that it's writing
about but you start to try to say
how can i be perceptive to recognize
how that situation is occurring right
now
where the art the artist the audience
the technology has moved forward
ahead of the legacy business and market
practices of the industry
you me all of us hopefully
will start to see that this similar
opportunity
where we can build a new model that can
allow
a ambitious and diverse film culture
to not just uh be sustainable
but to also thrive that's what i hope
is the hope for film that people find in
the book